all right so screen four was actually i
did a review of screen four when it came
out i
didn't watch the whole old review
because watching my old videos it's
tough for me but i did skip to the
writing
like some of you do i'm looking at you i
was like t-minus immediately
wow i did not like scream four when it
came out apparently but
youtube tells me it's been nine years so
you know growth and perspective and
things change and i just think
scream four is worth revisiting as i do
my monday stream day so here we go
screen four
[Music]
scruffform i'll never not call it that
which makes me look forward to scream
five cause you know they're going to
turn the s into a five so it's like
five cream five cream you scream we all
scream for
five cream i want them to title at that
just because i wanna say that again in a
youtube video
also spoiler warning spoilers for screen
four it's less
weird giving spoiler warning for a movie
that's 10 years old than it is
a movie that's 25 years old but whatever
or so screen 4 came out in 2011 it
promised new decade
new rules scream was planned to be a
trilogy and when it was done
it was done but as the horror movie
genre changed
the wes craven saw opportunity there and
he's like all right let's
instead of making a movie that copy
scream let's just make another scream
it's all right enter scream 4
sydney prescott has written a book she
returns to woodsboro
dewey and gail weathers they're married
they've been married for 10 years
i didn't think they'd make it that long
but they did then the ghosts face
killings start again and here we go
new scream movie with a new cast a
merging of two generations and
new victims and really when i look at
scream four i'm
tempted to compare it to scream 3 and
see what scream 4 has over scream 3 and
it really depends on
what angle you're coming at screen 4
from there's something scream 3 does
have over scream 4 right out the gate
like i said in my scream 3 review scream
3 does have that feeling of
finality you feel like it's the
concluding chapter of the trilogy it
feels like it's all wrapped up it feels
like that you know it's
it's on a nice neat little bow though
you know the plot of scream three is
a little more out there than the other
two screen four does feel detached
there's a few things making it feel that
way it's naturally going to feel that
way because
new decade ten years later and all but
it does feel like scream one two and
three are all hanging out in a house
together because
they're that trilogy and is kind of
hanging out on the porch but that's not
to say scream 4 doesn't have some solid
things going for it right out the gate
we're going to talk about ghostface
ghostface is back my friends and he's
back with a vengeance it is kind of
funny when i talk about ghostface like
ghostface has been
seven people at this point but when i
talk about ghostface it's like oh
ghostface
the person is back it's it's not even
the same person
it's that concept that the legend is
bigger than the ones that play the
characters like
batman dread pirate roberts and scream
i'll illustrate that concept best it's
kind of wild for a horror movie to be up
there
on that kind of pedestal with that
concept of characters but it is for me
so when i say ghostface is back i really
mean it kevin williamson is the writer
of this movie he wrote scream one and
two
not three also this isn't coming fresh
off of the columbine shooting so there
wasn't that push to
censor scream four whereas there was a
push to censor scream three
so ghost face in this movie is ghostface
unhinged and everything from the phone
calls
to the kills i love them he says some
dark [ __ ] on the phone in this movie i
mean
top tier ghostface dick move is when he
tells sydney if you hang up on me you'll
die just like your mother and it kind of
sounds like babies from beavers and butt
head when he does if you hang up on me
you'll die just like your mother
he's like you want to die sydney your
mother sure didn't
that's messed up stuff to say i mean
that's up there
scream for he's like i'll cut your
eyelids open so you don't miss a thing
i'll slice your neck and i won't stop
until i hit bone i'm sure i'm misquoting
ghostface but
intense phone calls on this movie also
some playful intense kills where his
scream 3 was basically like alright
a knife and you're dead for the most
part this movie's like alright knife
well that was kind of boring let's throw
that person over the roof have them
land on a news van during the police
giving their statement to the news there
you go there's some flair that one kill
where he's on the phone he's like i'm in
the closet hayden panettiere's like no
you're not and he's like i didn't say i
was in your closet and all they can do
is look through the window to next door
and watch their friend get slaughtered
that playfulness is dark the [ __ ] he
said on the phone was messed up and that
attack is intense
and when sydney walks up those stairs
man it looks like the crime scene from
dexter morgan's
mom did ghost's face have a chainsaw his
blood spatter all over the walls
intestines hanging out
that kill was basically scream four
being like
scream is back baby and most importantly
ghostface returns
to take his revenge
on doors so i really love ghostface in
this movie and i do consider
ghostface and killer reveal two
different things but
ghostface on the phone in the outfit
in the mask killing people top tier
ghost face in scream 4. this movie does
have to balance okay so it's been 10
years so we have this new generation
and the original older generation who do
we prioritize
we've seen things do that and some do it
well like cobra cow you don't have to
choose you can have the older generation
and the new generation
interweave in one plot that actually
is fulfilling but in a world where this
is a slasher film and people have to die
in scream you do have to choose and they
erred on the side of caution and they
went with the correct choice and being
like okay we'll go ahead and prioritize
the older generation and the new
generation they can be there to die so
that's what the new generation's here
for they're here to die
what can i say but because it's been a
decade
in the previous scream trilogy that's
all wrapped up the original generation
they don't feel safe there was one time
i was like oh i guess gail weathers is
about to die and
i guess sydney just died the movie lets
them live but it also keeps you on your
toes and i appreciate that that said
yeah new generation didn't really care
about them i just saw opportunities for
people to die hopefully creatively and
maybe that's because i'm more attached
to the original scream cast or the three
surviving members
of it but when i look at scream one and
you have sydney
randy billy stu tatum they're all
hanging out
they feel like a group of friends little
did sydney know two of them are dicks
the friends in this movie this is what i
call them
hayden panetta and her meat shields
because that's what her friends are
they're there to die and she is hands
down
the most interesting one of the newbies
they played it well with her character
and she played the character well i feel
like most of the horror movies in this
situation be like okay
we need to have the hot chick then we
can have the girl with attitude then we
can have a new horror movie nerd
but we'll have that person be a girl
screen four was like
great but instead of having three
separate characters why don't we crush
those three concepts
into one character making hands down the
most interesting and
layered of the new characters granted i
mean she dies
so that's a bummer who would have liked
her to live because i wanted to be in
screen five because she was the most
interesting one and the movie does
actually fulfill its promise of new
decade new rules it does give you a
glimpse into okay this is what horror's
like now this is what it's about now and
in the end it's the couple of people who
want to get famous off of snuff films
that they've made like they're recording
their killings now
they're making the movie they're not
waiting for hollywood to do it and that
totally fits it totally makes sense and
it justifies the movie's existence in
that sense i will say as much as i love
the ghostface
killings in scream 4 when the killers
are unmasked it kinda loses me i don't
know if it's the fact that i don't buy
emma roberts as
ghostface i don't buy emma roberts as
the killer the implication is she's the
one who fought gail weathers
i feel like gail weathers would just
kick her [ __ ] ass courtney cox looks
like she hits the bowflex this 75 pound
girl is going to come at her with a
knife
granted a knife does balance the
equation to a point but i feel like
she'll just give her the nightfall in
about two seconds and that'll be that
it'll be over but i suppose
for what they're going for it works like
i mean if we're just walking through it
as i'm
just mentally walking through it right
now when the ghostface killer or killers
take off the mask and like okay
now the killers are revealed there's
always a feeling that i get you know
scream one with stu and billy
it was more intense for me the ghostface
thing was the gimmick but man when
they're unmasked i
feel more uneasy most of which is
probably because of matthew lillard's
epic
unhinged performance but still it's just
like dude
these guys are psychos mrs loomis didn't
freak me out as much as
mickey but when the ghostface mask comes
off same
feeling with mickey not as intense as
with stew but still that feeling of
unease is there
roman i just felt like he needed a hug
you know i'm like oh your mom
she abandoned you she totally denied you
a life
i'm sorry he just he's a sad dude with a
sad life and this just kind of
started the whole thing off when the
ghostface masks came off in scream four
i wasn't scared of these brats though i
do see that there is a
valuable lesson in there about internet
and social media clout chasing it's in
line with the plot still doesn't change
the fact that by the end it was like
okay so
those those are the killers that's fine
i suppose it would have worked better if
sydney's aunt
was in the previous scream movies and i
don't know i guess she's in woodsboro
was she like oh my niece is getting
stalked
don't care maybe you would have seen
this little kid and that was jill and
she would have grown it like you know
like that would have
made it work more for me it just feels
like they were like all right we need to
write in a new family member because we
need a new family member because we need
a new killer and we need a new
motivation and
so it does feel like an afterthought on
a personal note and technical level i'm
not really a fan of how the movie looks
it's like it has that smoothing filter
i've seen some 4k movies used to remove
some of the film grain so all their
faces look
washed out and waxy some of the light
from the background bleeds over onto
people in the foreground
and the light on their faces looks too
bright like everyone has a lamp two feet
from their face i just prefer the more
natural look of the 90s scream movies
doesn't change the fact that for an
afterthought for the horror element
i actually dug screamed for it's not as
tight-knit as scream one and two i still
feel like it could have
ended after scream two but for a new
scream movie that wants to poke at how
horror movies had changed in the early
2010s
found footage movies just exploded at
that time so the killer's motivation is
to
essentially create found footage
killings that that works but what makes
the movie for me are the ghostface phone
calls on the ghostface killings
ghostface is intense in this movie over
time i feel like scream 4
though it does feel like an afterthought
i think it's a good time no alcohol
required but most of all i want to give
scream 4
and all the scream movies credit for
making
sydney prescott the center for all this
time
most horror movies i mean let's face it
we watched nightmare on elm street
for freddy krueger a lot of horror
movies the killer becomes the star
and ghostface is a star in scream but it
never compromises it all revolving
around sydney prescott that's a very
rare thing in the horror movie field
and scream just deserves props for that
all right so screw
form always gonna call it that have you
seen it have you watched it did you
watch it when it came out did you
re-watch it recently
what do you think about it does it get
better over time has it gotten worse
over time
is it just the same as you've always
seen it whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you